i think one of the most common problems
that people have is not that they don't
know what to do to dramatically move
their life forward in a substantial way
like you know exactly what you need to
do right now there's probably something
that you've been avoiding like the
plague but the problem is not that you
don't know what that is the problem is
that you just can't bring yourself to do
it and that's the common theme every
single day is that when you sit down to
do this thing you feel a feeling and it
almost seems unfair how potent this
feeling of resistance is because it's
usually only present when you think
about doing things that are genuinely
good for you so it's it's like what's
the deal with that why does it seem like
life is set up that way wouldn't it be
better if you just actually enjoyed
doing difficult things wouldn't it be
better if you actually had the
motivation to be creative or to write a
paper or to do your taxes like you
probably want nothing more than to be
someone who genuinely enjoys and looks
forward to doing the things that are
good for you doing the things that
empower you recently i've been thinking
there is one strategy that i have that
works every single time it always makes
me do the thing that i need to do it's
not very flattering it's not very sexy
we don't want to believe that this is
the answer and i feel like there's so
much self-improvement advice out there
that kind of ignores this fundamental
not even tactic it's almost a fact of
life and when we ignore this fact we'll
try to do little tips and tricks like oh
set a timer for five minutes and just
really try try really hard to do the
work or try to think more positive
thoughts about your work but all those
strategies like they're kind of
throwaway strategies yeah they might
work here or there but they get old
really quick this strategy is nuclear so
if you need to do one particular thing
then if you do this you will do it like
you will have no choice the solution is
boredom ironically that's also the
problem the solution and the problem are
the same thing you don't want to do that
work because it's so boring to your
brain you want to gouge your eyes out
all of these distractions that you have
around sound so much more entertaining
than doing that thing so you always have
a back door why in hell would you write
an essay when you could be checking
instagram when you could be watching
youtube videos like this one but the key
realization is that your brain doesn't
see objective entertainment values it's
always relative a good analogy for this
is when you're spending all day outside
in the sun it's a super bright day and
then you walk into a dim room or a store
that indoor space feels super dark
you're like man i can't see anything
what is this and then you see that weird
like fake sun in your periphery that
starts to fade everything looks like
weird and purpley and in a very similar
way if you've been asleep for a couple
hours and you have to get up and go to
the bathroom you turn the lights on and
it's just blinding it's not that that
bathroom is any more bright than it was
before you went to bed when you were
brushing your teeth it's just that your
brain interprets things using contrasts
it uses comparison so the key is to
utterly delete the back doors the key is
to strip away every single option to sit
in a blank room with nothing in it no
phone nothing eliminate your ability to
do anything other than the thing that
you need to do and you will do it and
now you might be thinking oh it's not
that simple i can just do nothing well
you actually won't do nothing and
there's studies to prove it there was a
really weird study published in science
in 2014 that was a mouthful it's not one
of my freaking neanderthal that's not a
mouthful that was really hard to say so
in this study they got a bunch of
undergraduate students to sit in a empty
room by themselves with absolutely
nothing to do and be alone with their
own thoughts but they had one other
option and that was to electrocute
themselves with a shocky button and it
turns out 67 of the men and 25 percent
of the women decided that electrocution
was better than boredom and some of the
students electrocuted themselves
multiple times even the ones that didn't
electrocute themselves either strongly
considered it or at least lamented as to
how miserable the quiet time was and how
boring it was you might have heard about
this study before but i think it's a
great example as to how much human
beings dislike being bored it's the
reason why solitary confinement is
considered one of the least humane forms
of torture imaginable there's this
ancient torture method where they
basically just throw somebody down a
hole under the castle and forget about
them like for their entire lives
number 15 the oobliet the last thing
you'd want after stealing a cup of
buckwheat is to end up in one of these
[ __ ] isn't that that sounds
terrible because it's so boring if you
are put in an empty room with nothing to
do except one thing unless that thing is
like chop off your hand you're probably
gonna do that thing and while you're
doing that thing that thing will feel so
much more entertaining than doing
nothing so you have to ask yourself what
are you constructing your life around
how are you structuring things are the
things that you're supposed to do
entertaining in comparison to the things
that you use as distractions because the
larger the disparity the more agonizing
that thing will be and you'll find very
quickly that if you delete distractions
as an option it works right away it's
insane this isn't like some dopamine
detox that you got to do over weeks and
months and years although that will help
you get used to finding the
entertainment value in difficult things
this is something that works right away
because your brain needs to to survive
it hates feeling bored so it will make
whatever your only option is as
entertaining as it needs to i even have
personal evidence for this one of the
most productive social and energetic
times in my entire life is when i was
living in a little 900 square foot
basement suite in the middle of suburbia
with absolutely nothing to do except
edit videos okay so here's alex looking
in the pantry for stuff to eat um these
guys are
cooked us our only good meal that we've
had in several days and basically this
whole video
is uh is basically just
to show off what we have going on in our
fridge right now
ketchup a little bit of milk
some
korean honey
three pickles
salsa and water
i was absolutely broke and to edit these
videos that i had to do for my very few
corporate freelance videography clients
i was sitting on an upside down laundry
hamper because i couldn't afford a uh
office chair but this was deeply
motivating to me although i did live
with my friend alex he was hardly ever
around so i had these long periods of
loneliness but that sting of loneliness
made me social it made me make plans it
made me seek opportunities my lack of
money made me seek money and most
importantly the lack of things to do in
there the lack of distractions that i
surrounded myself with made me extremely
bored bored enough that editing videos
and being highly creative and doing what
i love actually felt entertaining as
well so there's a perfect example of my
environmental conditioning helping
facilitate a mindset of creativity and
attitude of productivity it's because i
had very few other options so in summary
if you have something you need to do
right now then eliminate all your back
doors turn off your phone remove your
gaming pc from your room remove your
xbox auto hide the toolbar so when
you're thinking of the next word to
write you don't look at safari and
automatically click on it and in living
life this way and treating productivity
this way it's not that you're going to
live a less entertaining life in fact
you might find it far more entertaining
and fulfilling and empowering than you
ever knew possible
and if you're looking for an excellent
way to have more stamina throughout the
day so that when you are actually doing
the things that you need to do you can
do it for longer it will probably help
to feel good mentally and physically
using today's video's sponsor athletic
greens you guys already know that ag-1
is by far my favorite supplement on the
planet it is an integral part of my
morning routine and it makes me feel so
good throughout the day i almost can't
believe it ag-1 supports your energy
focus gut health immunity mental clarity
without the need to take multiple
products or pills and i think the reason
i feel so good while i'm taking it is
because there's almost no competing with
the amount of vitamins and nutrients in
just one scoop of this stuff and the
fact that it's sourced from real food
real superfoods condensed down into a
bioavailable form means that your body
can actually use it it absorbs it really
well so you're not just urinating it out
so if you guys are interested in joining
me in participating in this very simple
health optimization habit that i've been
doing for around two years now then use
my link in the description below and
you'll also get a year's supply of their
vitamin d3 and k2 complex which i also
have every single morning as well as
five ag-1 travel packs with your first
purchase so take advantage of that link
below optimize your health feel
fantastic and as usual have a great time
if you liked this video then if you
actually hit the like button that's a
huge help because the video will rank
better shoving my bald head into other
people's homepages helping them out
which also helps me out so it is a
win-win for everybody involved if you've
seen my face a couple of times and you
like my videos consider subscribing and
hitting up the instagram sometimes i
post some memey silly
[ __ ] on there
um
and it's just fun other than that though
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video
you